hi my name is raj with google cloud and
in this video we're going to go over the
creation of a private cloud within
google cloud vmware engine
the first thing we're going to do is log
into the cloud console at
console.cloud.google.com
and let's go ahead and click on the main
menu and select vmware engine under the
compute section of the main menu as you
can see vmware engine shows up as a
first class citizen just like any other
google cloud service within the menu
options
now the first time you launch google
cloud vmware engine you'll have to
enable the api first
this is a one-time step for the first
time you're attempting to provision and
create your private
cloud once the api has been enabled
we'll go back to the menu again and
click on vmware engine from the menu
once more
and once the screen loads what we'll be
in is the main google cloud vmware
engine portal
where we can configure and deploy our
first private cloud
all right let's go ahead and click on
the new private cloud button to create
our vmware environment
first thing we're going to do in the new
screen here is go ahead and give it a
name
to denote the name of the private cloud
or the software defined data center
environment
this is going to be called in the rks
gcp-demo
next we're going to select which
location it's going to go in
within the location you're going to
select the geo
physical location where the private
cloud gets created
wherever it might be in the world
in our case we're just going to go ahead
and select australia here and you also
get to select
what's called a placement group and this
is where
the rows of compute or the capacity
selection
is made along with where your private
cloud goes
next we'll select the node type and in
this case this will be the standard 72
which is a 72 threaded physical hardware
36 physical cores
three quarters of a terabyte of memory
and around 19.2 terabytes of raw
nvme space along with 3.2 terabytes of
cash
next we're going to select whether to do
a multi-node deployment or a single node
deployment
single node deployments are typically
used for a proof-of-concept or lab or
testing type scenario
whereas the multi-node is more for a
production based environment so we're
going to select multi-node here
and next you'll notice that we have a
customized core option
the customized core option allows you to
disable cores on a node
in order to bring down the number of
cores available
to the hypervisor the reason for this
may be related to perhaps application
licensing
requirements maybe you're running a
certain application that requires you to
license
the whole physical server in which case
you may want to create a custom cluster
with reduced core counts in order to
limit the impact on your application
licensing
next we'll need two sideranges one is
for our vsphere
vsan nsxt management components
and the next one is for our hcx
deployment ranges which is the migration
tool built into google cloud vmware
engine
we'll go ahead and click review and
create and if you get a sign that says
you can provision in fast mode this
means that we can provision vcenter and
the esxi nodes at around 30 minutes
which is an extremely fast time
so we'll go ahead and click create at
this time and within around 30 minutes
your environment should be ready for you
to log into vcenter now that our cloud
is operational you can see here that our
private cloud has been provisioned let's
go ahead and grab the password for our
vcenter login and the username and there
are two ways where we can reach the
vcenter url you can either click on
vsphere management network
or we can click on the launch vsphere
client button
now that we've gone ahead and clicked on
that button we can see that we're
greeted by the browser screen with the
vcenter url let's go ahead and log into
vcenter with our cloud owner credentials
and the password that we copied from the
previous screen
as you can see the vcenter view here is
very similar and familiar to the one
that you might see on an on-prem
environment
which provides a consistent experience
with managing a vmware environment in
the cloud
now that you know how to deploy your own
dedicated private cloud on google cloud
vmware engine check out the other videos
in this series to learn how to configure
the infrastructure and migrate your
workloads to the cloud to learn more
about google cloud vmware engine visit
our site at cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you